we begin with that breaking news in the
last hour regarding the condition of the
russian activist
alexei navalny the hospital caring for
him in berlin
says tests show evidence of poisoning
doctors say mr navalny remains in an
artificial coma and is in a
serious condition but his life is not
believed to be
in danger let's turn to our defense and
security correspondent aleister bunker
who joins us now from berlin
alice out of immediate danger but when
he wakes up from his coma if he wakes up
from his coma he may not be the same man
indeed we've been waiting for best part
of three days for a medical update
either from the hospital or from alexa
navalny's
family or team everybody's been very
tight-lipped up until
as you say about an hour ago when we got
a very full statement
about his latest condition and a
statement from the hospital
basically confirming that in their
opinion he was poisoned let me read
some of that statement to you they say
the patient that is alexander vanilli
is in an intensive care unit and is
still in
an artificial coma his state of health
is serious
but there is currently no acute danger
to his life
the team of doctors has examined the
patient thoroughly after his arrival
the clinical findings indicate
intoxication by a substance
from the chlorescence clonira stays
inhibitor group
the specific substance has not been
identified so far and a further
wide-ranging analysis has been initiated
and in the longer statement they point
out that those tests have been run a
number of times
and have been independently verified of
course what they're trying to do is uh
establish beyond any doubt
the credibility behind their findings
given that it'll be reasonably
controversial
the kremlin no doubt will probably
disagree with them it also is contrary
to what the doctors
uh who initially treated alexander
navalny in russia had to say
about it and they go on to say that
there could be long-term effects
to his health now in terms of um that
group of
of of toxins uh i in the last half an
hour since the statement came out
spoke to a chemical weapons expert i
know who said it could point towards
nerve agents so those toxins can be used
to treat things like alzheimer's
but they can also be used in far more
nefarious
uh circumstances like nerve agents as
well so
some questions remain precisely being
what what it was
but the the toxin what toxin it was that
poisoned
alexey navalny but this is a very false
statement
and quite a turn of events
as now german doctors and german
scientists seem to confirm that he was
poisoned
alastair thanks a lot